es ist halb zehn am Abend als Jens
dolttenberg die Sätze spricht mit denen
fast kaum einer noch gerechnet hatte
guten Abend ich hatte einen sehr
konstruktives Treffen mit dem türkischen
Präsidenten und dem schwedischen premier
ich bin sehr froh dass Präsident Erdogan
jetzt zugesagt hat den Parlament die
Ratifizierung des schwedischen
nato-beitritts vorzulegen und zwar so
schnell wie möglich
aus Ankara provoziert mit einer ganz
neuen Bedingung
öffnet erst den Weg für den Beitritt der
Türkei zur Europäischen Union und dann
öffnen wir den Weg für Schweden in die
NATO doch davon ist später kaum noch die
Rede Schweden sagt zu seinen Kampf gegen
Terrorismus erneut zu verschärfen und
der türkische Präsident sagt ja und so
kann sich die NATO jetzt dem
eigentlichen Thema dieses Gipfels
zuwenden ganz Vilnius trägt Blau-Gelb
die Farben der Ukraine die NATO so
hoffen die Gastgeber soll hier
beschließen dass die Ukraine direkt nach
dem Krieg der Allianz Beitritt nein ist
das perfekt
ist extrem wichtig für ein Land das so
mutig gegen das russische Monster kämpft
muss der Ort sein von dem was
ukrainische Volk aus gute Nachrichten
bekommt doch gegen eine quasi
automatische Einladung der Ukraine gibt
es Widerstand er kommt vor allem vom
wichtigsten Staatschef der NATO schon
vor seiner Anreise dämpft der
US-Präsident ukrainische Hoffnungen
ich glaube die NATO ist sich nicht einig
darüber die Ukraine jetzt in die
nato-familie aufzunehmen in diesem
Moment wo ein Krieg herrscht
im Falle Schwedens schrammt die da
Gipfel knapp am Scheitern vorbei im Fall
der Ukraine muss das erst noch gelingen
und aus Vilnius vom NATO-Gipfel ist mehr
unser USA-Korrespondent el MRT Wissens
zugeschaltet der den US-Präsidenten
begleitet guten Morgen Elmar Joe Biden
hat die Entscheidung der Türkei ja
begrüßt dem NATO-Beitritt Schwedens
endlich zuzustimmen und teilte mit dass
er bereit sei mit dem türkischen
Präsidenten verstärkt zusammen zu
arbeiten waren die USA also insgeheim
doch Teil des schwedendeals oder wie ist
das zu verstehen
so jedenfalls sieht es die US-Regierung
ich komme gerade aus einem
Pressegespräch mit Jake Sullivan dem
nationalen Sicherheitsberater der USA
und Saline hat uns gerade gesagt dass
Joe beiden in den nächsten Tagen das
Paket über F16 Kampfjets in den
amerikanischen Kongress einbringen wird
da geht es um einen Auftrag in einem
Volumen von 20 Milliarden Dollar darüber
haben ganz offenbar Erdogan und beiden
am Sonntag auch gesprochen in ihrem
Telefonat wir haben nachgefragt in wie
weit das möglicherweise den Ausschlag
gegeben hat aber salvin hat im Grunde
nur klar gemacht Joe Biden habe Erdogan
gesagt welche wichtige positive Rolle er
hier spielen könnte er hat natürlich
zugesagt dass die USA dieses Paket
voranbringen wollen es gibt Chancen dass
das durch den Kongress kommt aber es ist
eben nicht klar dass am Ende den
Ausschlag gegeben hat nur für erdogan
ist es glaube ich das gewesen was er
realistisch erreichen kann dieses Paket
von F16 Kampfjets er konnte sicherlich
nicht erreichen eine mögliche Zusage
eben für einen EU zweiten Schritt die
allerdings von den USA auch unterstützt
würde wenn die EU das hat zahlleben sehr
klar gemacht selber zu dem Schluss kommt
dass man die Türkei in die EU aufnehmen
will gut nachdem der NATO-Beitritt
Schwedens also offenbar geklärt ist wird
sich heute in Vilnius ja alles auf die
Ukraine konzentrieren was es in diesem
Punkt zu erwarten
gerade noch mal aus sehr deutlich gesagt
jetzt ein Beitritt der Ukraine kommt
nicht in Frage weil das als
Kriegseintritt der NATO gegen Russland
gewertet werden könnte aber man ist sich
einig innerhalb der Allianz dass die
Ukraine ein legitim ein rechtmäßiger
Partner der NATO werden soll ein
Mitglied der NATO das Wann und das wie
das wird hier offen gelassen und man
will das Signal aussetzen das ist nicht
das Entscheidende hier bei diesem Gipfel
das über Erfolg oder Misserfolg
entscheidet sondern wichtiger ist dass
man hier in der NATO geschlossen ist
dass man vor allen Dingen beschließen
wird einen Plan wie man künftig gegen
die Bedrohung durch Russland sich
verteidigen kann also so eine Art
Kriegsplan und wie man sicherstellt dass
die NATO die entsprechenden Waffen und
auch die entsprechende Munition hat um
das langfristig zu tun ob nun mit oder
der UK oder oder ohne der Ukraine als
Mitglied innerhalb der NATO
war das vielen Dank für deine Einordnung
aus Vilnius und damit kommen wir jetzt
zurück zu uns ins Studio Michael Roth
von der SPD ist bei uns der Vorsitzende
des Auswärtigen Ausschusses im Bundestag
guten Morgen herzlich willkommen hallo
Frau Waldenfels nach Erpressung aus dann
plötzlich zieht Erdogan zurück und macht
den Weg frei das Schweden in die NATO
eintreten kann hat sie das überrascht
und erleichtert
autoritäre Herrscher brauchen den Boden
Zauber wie ihre Zimmerpflanzen das
Sonnenlicht das ist nun mal so er hat ja
auch dafür was erhalten erstmal hat er
seiner eigenen
Landsmannschaft in der Türkei deutlich
gemacht dem Westen habe ich mal wieder
so richtig gezeigt und auf dem Tisch
gehauen und zum anderen bekommt er jetzt
die F16 Kampfjets um die er ja lange
gebeten hat aber die klugerweise
Präsident beiden so lange verwehrt hat
bis es dann auch grünes Licht gibt für
den NATO-Beitritt Schwedens der wichtig
ist für uns alle das ist das was der
US-Präsident Joe Biden seitens der NATO
versprochen hat die von Ihnen
angesprochenen F16 Kampfjets offiziell
heißt es hinzu noch Schweden hätte
versprochen seinen Kampf gegen den
Terror noch mal zu verstärken das war ja
auch ein Punkt auf den Erdogan sehr
gepocht hat aber das kann doch nicht das
Einzige sein was Präsident Erdogan von
der EU bekommen hat denn er hatte ja
gefordert eine klare Perspektive auf
eine EU-Mitgliedschaft könnte da noch
was anderes dahinter stecken diese
Forderung ist wirklich mehr als absurd
das ist doch kein wir sind doch keine
keine dealmaker sondern um Mitglied
eines Teams zu werden muss man
Bedingungen erfüllen während Schweden
die Bedingungen für ein NATO-Beitritt
voll umfänglich erfüllt hat und es nur
aufgrund von innenpolitischen Erwägungen
Erdogan und Herrn Orban in Ungarn
schwergefallen ist grünes Licht zu
erteilen ist unter der Herrschaft von
den Erdogan die Türkei meilenweit von
den Bedingungen entfernt die wichtig
sind für einen Beitritt also ist es kann
man das nicht miteinander vermengen da
hat der Bundeskanzler völlig recht
trotzdem noch mal die Frage ob sie
glauben dass es seitens der EU noch
irgendein Zugeständnis in Richtung
Erdogan gegeben hat oder ob es
tatsächlich nur die F16 Kampfjets aus
den USA sind ich kann mir das nicht
vorstellen weil jeder in der
Europäischen Union wissen müsste auf so
einen Kuhhandel könnte man sich nicht
einlassen wir sind eine
Wertegemeinschaft und wir sind hier
nicht irgendwie
auf einem Basar oder auf einer Kirmes
bei mir zu Hause im Dorf und verhandeln
über sowas das geht nicht es geht um
klare Bedingungen die erfüllt werden
müssen das ist ein sehr transparenter
Prozess und wenn
Erdogan wieder den Kurs der Demokratie
der Rechtsstaatlichkeit und der Freiheit
in der Türkei einschlägt dann könnte das
durchaus auch wieder was werden mit
einer Ernährung zwischen der Türkei und
der Europäischen Union ich würde mir das
wünschen so weit erstmal zur
NATO-Erweiterung Schwedens und einer
Frage der EU-Mitgliedschaft der Türkei
dann geht es heute natürlich auch um
eine NATO-Beitritt dabei
Beitrittsperspektive für die Ukraine
gerade die baltischen und viele
osteuropäische Staaten wünschen sich ja
dass die Ukraine ein rechtmäßigen Platz
im Bündnis hat der deutsche Kanzler
sträubt sich dagegen warum
nicht nur der deutsche Bundeskanzler hat
ein paar kritische Anmerkungen dazu
gemacht sondern vor allem Präsident
beiden der will das partout nicht ich
habe Herrn saliwan Sullivan den
nationalen Sicherheit gefragt nach dem
deutschen Bundeskanzler aber der
Bundeskanzler orientiert sich hier sehr
stark an dem stärksten Player in der
NATO und das ist der amerikanische
Präsident was ich nicht ganz verstehe
Herr Salewa hat eben gesagt man können
nicht für einen sofortigen NATO-Beitritt
der Ukraine eintreten das will doch gar
niemand der Krieg muss beendet sein erst
dann kann die Ukraine beitreten jetzt
reden war über viel dass der Ukraine
helfen wird mehr militärische
Unterstützung es wird einen Ukraine
naturat geben es wird auch hoffentlich
sicherheitszusagen für die Ukraine geben
aber ich hätte mir gewünscht wir werden
dem Rad unserer polnischen und
baltischen Freundin und Freunde gefolgt
ganz kurz das Argument für eine
NATO-Beitritt laut Experten ist ja wenn
der NATO-Beitritt erst für nach dem
Krieg in Aussicht gestellt würde wäre
das ein Anreiz für Putin zu sagen gut
dann halten wir den Krieg möglichst
lange aufrecht ja das ist alles kein
risikobefreiter Weg aber wenn wir jetzt
über sicherheitszusagen sprechen und ist
wir sollten die Diskussion auch in
Deutschland endlich mal intensiver
führen dann sollten wir das Pro und
Contra abwägen ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen das sicherheitszusagen
einiger weniger Länder so viel
Abschreckung gegenüber Russland
aufbringen wie die wie die Einbeziehung
der Ukraine in ein kollektives
sicherheitsbündnis wie die NATO sie
haben dazu ein ganz konkreten Vorschlag
gemacht auch schon diskutiert wurde
sollten die freien Gebiete der Ukraine
in die NATO welcher war ihr Vorschlag
was haben sie damit gemeint also der
Vorschlag bezieht sich natürlich auf das
Erpressungspotenzial ein Potenz wenn
Herr Putin in der Ukraine irgendeinen
eingefrorenen Konflikt schafft wie in
Moldau oder in Georgien dann würde es ja
niemals eine Beitrittsperspektive geben
und ich gehe mal davon aus dass es unter
Umständen bei einer Friedenslösung
zwischen Russland und der Ukraine noch
nicht alle Probleme gelöst gibt und für
einen solchen Fall sollte man auch
erwägen dass man trotz eines
eingefrorenen Konflikts die Ukraine
aufnehmen könnte um ein Gebiete der
Ukraine und nicht die von Russland
gesetzt besetzten gebietet unser Ziel
ist es dass die Ukraine ein freies
demokratisches Land bleibt unter
vollständiger Wahrung ihrer
territorialen Integrität ich will hier
nicht über eine Friedenslösung
spekulieren aber wir müssen doch auch
über ein Instrument zumindestens in der
Hinterhand verfügen sollte Herr Putin
wirklich auf einen eingefrorenen
Konflikt beharren denn dann wäre die
NATO Mitgliedschaft wenn wir das sehr
streng auslegen
nur ganz kurz damit wir das Szenario
dass jeder aufmachen auch wirklich
verstehen dass diese bei einem
eingefrorenen Konflikt einem
Waffenstillstand würde
das Szenario folgendermaßen aussehen
wenn z.B auf freies ukrainisches Gebiet
wie hier eine russische Rakete fliegt
dann würde der Bündnisfall ausgegangen
es gibt ja eine Friedenslösung also noch
einmal die NATO Mitgliedschaft und das
ist die Auffassung aller kann erst nach
dem Krieg erfolgen aber eine
Friedenslösung kann ja unter Umständen
auch bedeuten das ist noch den einen
oder anderen territorialen Konflikt dass
der ungelöst bleibt das haben wir im
Übrigen jetzt schon seit vielen Jahren
in Georgien oder auch in Moll dabei das
Länder die sich ja auch aufmachen in
Richtung Europäische Union und ich
möchte nur dass wir ein Putin kein
Erpressungspotenzial in die Hand geben
Michael Roth war das der Vorsitzende vom
Auswärtigen Ausschuss von der SPD ganz
herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch ich
danke Ihnen